vegas woman set out to make a change in
our community by offering something no
one else was free vegan food well the
idea caught on and now the last vegan
food bank is dishing out help in the
form of produce and grains heather mills
takes us to their distribution site
serving up a niche market
according to one website citing the
number of vegans vegan restaurants and
vegan groups nevada is number one in the
u.s in fact there's 14 000 people who
follow the las vegas vegans facebook
page vegan food staples they tend to be
less expensive than meat but with the
price of everything going up there's a
market
and there's certainly a need
whether by choice or doctor ordered
veganism is growing in popularity but in
a desert where growing food can be
somewhat of a challenge and with rising
food prices a lot of folks need the
extra help
there was more of a need in the
community because of
because of people experiencing
the side effects of kovid and
the economy the initial idea was mine
but the rest has been a complete
collaborative effort of all of our staff
volunteers the concept of the vegan food
bank bloomed and really began taking
shape at the end of 2020. our goal from
the start has been to feed our community
food with high nutritional value and
then our boxes are full of produce dry
goods and shelf safe items multi-grain
hearty healthy items and no animal
products we are a vegan establishment so
no meat no dairy no eggs no honey
partnering with united movement
organized kindness and purple carrot
this grassroots organization is really
taking seed hi there welcome first name
please they've already packed and
distributed thousands and thousands of
boxes of food with distributions
happening the second and fourth saturday
of the month
they're generating community support and
forming bonds with one another it's
great putting the boxes together meeting
the fellow vegans talking about food
recipe and just supporting supporting
the being a vegan jim larson runs a
halfway house in town he heard about the
food pantry from one of his residents
this is the first time they've been over
here but i think it's great that they're
having quality food
and being able to because nutrition is a
major major part of anybody's recovery
and part of mindy portinga's journey to
give back as the founder of lost vegan
food bank we do it because we care about
our community the lost vegan food bank
is working to obtain grants in order to
increase their distributions we've put
up a link at eight newsnow dot com if
you need help or you'd like to donate
food or volunteer for a distribution
heather mills live local now
you're